How to write a good issue on GitHub? GitHub
is the main place for the Hugging Face open
source libraries, and should always go there
to report a bug or ask for a new feature. For
more general questions or to debug your own code,
use the forums (see the video linked below). It's
very important to write good issues as it will
help the bug you uncovered be fixed in no time.
For this video, we have created a version of
Transformers with a bug. You can install it by
executing this command in a notebook (remove the
exclamation mark to execute it in a terminal).
In this version, the following example fails. The
error is rather cryptic and does not seem to come
from anything in our code, so it seems we have a
bug to report! The first thing to do in this case
is to try to find the smallest amount of
code possible that reproduces the bug.
In our case, inspecting the traceback, we see the
failure happens inside the pipeline function when
it calls AutoTokenizer.from_pretrained. Using the
debugger, we find the values passed to that method
and can thus create a small sample of code
that hopefully generates the same error.
It's very important to go though this step as you
may realize the error was on your side and not
a bug in the library, but it also will make it
easier for the maintainers to fix your problem.
Here we can play around a bit more with
this code and notice the error happens
for different checkpoints and not just this one,
and that it disappears when we use use_fast=False
inside our tokenizer call. The important part
is to have something that does not depend on any
external files or data. Try to replace your data
by fake values if you can't share it. With all
of this done, we are ready to start writing our
issue. Click on the button next to Bug Report and
you will discover there is a template to fill. It
will only take you a couple of minutes. The first
thing is to properly name your issue. Don't pick
a title that is too vague! Then you have to fill
your environment information. There is a command
provided by the Transformers library to do this.
Just execute it in your notebook or in
a terminal, and copy paste the results.
There are two last questions to fill manually
(to which the answers are no and no in our case).
Next, we need to determine who to tag. There is
a full list of usernames. Since our issue has
to do with tokenizers, we pick the maintainer
associated with them. There is no point tagging
more than 3 people, they will redirect you
to the right person if you made a mistake.
Next, we have to give the information
necessary to reproduce the bug.
We paste our sample, and put it between two
lines with three backticks so it's formatted
properly. We also paste the full traceback, still
between two lines of three backticks. Lastly,
we can add any additional information about
what we tried to debug the issue at hand.
With all of this, you should expect an answer to
your issue pretty fast, and hopefully, a quick
fix! Note that all the advise in this video
applies for almost every open-source project.